sadly bringing you this breaking news on
herman cain we are just getting
uh word that he has passed away due to
coronavirus complications we know that
he had been hospitalized
after he was diagnosed with covid19 the
former
presidential candidate and business
executive has passed away his website
has put out
a statement saying that we are
heartbroken and the world is poor herman
cain has gone to be
with the lord it begins you're never
ready for the kind of news that we're
grappling with this morning but we have
no choice but to seek and find god's
strength and comfort
to deal with it we know that he was
hospitalized among
the one of the highest profile figures
in the us to have
contracted the virus and now he has
passed away a 74 year old survivor
of stage 4 colon cancer he was a
business executive as you all know
board chairman of a branch of kansas
city's federal reserve bank
before moving into republican politics
and eventually becoming
a presidential candidate so the country
will mourn the loss of herman cain
just getting word that he has passed
away john roberts is live at the white
house on that news
this morning john and the last time that
i saw herman cain was at president
trump's rally in
tulsa oklahoma he waved as he went by
and it was not long after that june the
29th that he was diagnosed with
coronavirus
and went to an atlanta hospital a month
after being diagnosed he remained
on a ventilator although people who were
close to him were saying that
it appeared as though he might be
getting better
the the word that went out was that his
organs were strong
that they were trying to heal his lungs
with an infusion of oxygen through a
ventilator
but but don't forget uh herman cain did
have some underlying conditions
back in 2006 he had colon cancer
which had spread to his liver he was
also 74 years old sandra
which put him right sort of at the apex
of that high
risk group of people who sometimes do so
badly
with coronavirus we also know that
african americans
suffer severe coronavirus disease at a
higher percentage than other people do
as
well so i covered his presidential
campaign
uh back in 2012. uh he'll always be
forever known as mr 999 when i was
stationed in our atlanta bureau he was a
frequent uh
visitor as well as he was a contributor
to fox news that is until we got the
remote camera put into his home
in stockbridge and then he no longer had
to make the drive to atlanta
but uh the sad news this morning that
after a long
battle much of it on a ventilator with
coronavirus
herman cain finally succumbed to the
illness hand is passed away this morning
at the age of 74. i missed a lot of
people
when he passed away he was co-chairing a
co-chair of the black
voices for trump he had attended the
president's
tulsa rally in june um
obviously that was one of the last times
that we had seen him publicly was
hospitalized for about a month but john
to go back to your
point as of an update from his team
via twitter facebook and his website
yesterday
he was still hospitalized but he was
being treated for oxygen
the doctor said his organs and systems
were still strong
unfortunately as is this disease that is
unpredictable and sometimes people
feel better or appear to be better and
then get worse
um they even said he's really getting
better which means it's working
and yeah it's like as i pointed out they
had
put out that statement on twitter about
the fact that they thought that it was
actually getting better but as dr mark
siegel
will tell you and dr manny will tell you
what sometimes happens with people
is they appear to be getting better and
then all of a sudden
because of a you know over overactive
immune system they get something called
a cytokine storm
which literally fills the lung with
fluids
and they and they basically drown of
their own lymphatic fluid
entering the lungs and um i mean it's
he he wouldn't have known what was
happening to him because when you're on
a ventilator you were put into a medical
coma
uh because you just couldn't stand
having that uh tube down your
uh your your throat and into your
trachea and the machine pumping your
lungs so he wouldn't have known
what was happening to him but so many
people around him did but
i'm not saying that that's what happened
but that's what we have seen happen
in many many cases in in people who are
in a similar
age and risk category as herman cain
that you could even look like you're
getting better and then all of a sudden
you go south very rapidly
and and death comes on very quickly as a
result he had just started hosting a new
show
he was very excited about it but his
website saying herman cain has gone to
be
with the lord and we mourn the loss of
herman cain this morning 74 years old
had been admitted to the hospital a
month ago due to covet 19
diagnosis john roberts if you could
stand by at the white house for us yeah
sandra if there's one just one other
thing i could point out at that tulsa
rally
uh everybody who was going to get close
to the president and that would have
incurred it included herman cain
and because i went through it myself
were tested for coronavirus
disease they had a couple of tents that
were set up outside of the
the center there in tulsa and uh he
would have tested negative
at that point otherwise he would not
have been allowed into the rallies so
something happened between tulsa and the
29th
where he contracted the virus not to say
he got it at the rally
there were some staffers who showed
positive
some secret service who showed positive
both prior to the rally actually
beginning
in the aftermath not to say that
happened to herman cain but
it's likely that he would have been
negative for coronavirus on that day
because he would have been tested would
have been tested he was hospitalized in
atlanta
on july 1st two days after being told
that he had tested positive
so herman cain has left us and as his
website says has gone to be with the
lord